so many people don't take risks or fear
of failure they don't start the business
they don't go create the art they want
to create or they don't go try out to be
in the play my life was not great
I was selling fax machines door-to-door
I was living with my mom I was like 25
years old I'm in of the belief system
for me in my journey to start small
think big and scale fast need motivation
whattcha top ten with believe nation
she's Sara Blakely and here's my take on
her top ten rules a success volume to
enjoy okay let's hit it off with rule
number one redefine failure growing up
my father used to ask my brother and me
what we had failed at at the dinner
table which was so interesting and he'd
celebrate it and he'd actually be
disappointed if I didn't have something
that I failed at that week so I can
remember saying dad dad I tried out for
this and I was horrible and he would
actually high-five me and say
congratulations way to go and what it
did was just reframe my dish definition
of failure failure for me became not
trying versus the outcome so so many
people don't take risks for fear of
failure they don't start the business
they don't go create the art they want
to create or they don't go try out to be
in the play or whatever it is for the
fear of failure and once you redefine
that for yourself and realize the
failure is just not trying then life
opens up to you in many ways and I would
also my dad would encourage me anytime
something didn't go the way I expected
it to or maybe I got embarrassed by a
situation to write down where the hidden
gifts were and what I got out of it and
I started realizing and everything there
was some amazing nugget that I wouldn't
have wanted to pass up rule number two
believe you famously started Spanx with
$5,000 in your bank account what was the
hardest part about getting Spanx off the
ground the hardest part about getting
things off the ground was definitely in
the very beginning when you have when
you first have an idea as an inventor
and you thought of something that
doesn't exist and you want to bring it
into the world there were two things
that were happening one was my own
self-doubt was a really hard part of the
journey and and then the beginning of
all the manufacturers that I was having
to cold call and talk to to try to get
my product made we're all men and it was
much harder to explain and to try to get
them to understand the concept of what
the product was so I heard the word know
for two straight years trying to get it
made which then increases the self-doubt
that can happen and one of the
interesting things about being an event
is you don't go to school for it there
isn't an inventor class
you can't major in inventing and so it's
really a belief system in yourself and
the willingness to look stupid or to
have people laugh at you or to fail at
something that you believe in you're
your own gut check on that and so it
takes a lot of confidence so that was
that was the hardest part of my journey
there was a lot of starting and stopping
and like am I crazy and everyone's
saying no and but I you know I kept
picking myself back up to pursue it
rule number three manifest your idea I
actually really manifested the idea so
you know it's like everyone's always
like how did you take an idea and then
start a business well it's how did you
even come up with the idea you know I
was in search of my idea and at the time
my life was not great I was selling fax
machines door-to-door I was living with
my mom I was like 25 years old and I
remember after a whole entire day of
being kicked out of office complexes
again all day or sometimes my business
card ripped up in my face I pulled off
the side of the road one day Cathy and I
was like I'm in the wrong movie like
what just happened call the director
called the producer this is not my life
this is not my movie and I went home
that night I wrote down my strengths or
what I thought I was good at and the
only thing you do good column really was
sales and I thought okay well I know I'm
good at selling what is it I like about
selling and I realized I like offering
something to someone that they need or
didn't know that they needed that can
improve their life or help them and so
in that moment I wrote down in my
journal I want to invent a product that
I can sell to millions of people that
will make them feel good and
[Applause]
and you know what and two years later
the idea came to me and and I was ready
for it you know people women had been
cutting the feet out of their pantyhose
for a long time and I only did it one
time but I had already asked the
universe for my idea and I said when it
comes I will not squander it and I will
take it and run with it
rule number four be courageous my dream
is for there to be many more female
inventors I'm hoping more more and more
women will have the courage to take that
risk it's a risk to invent something you
have to risk being made fun of you have
to risk looking like an idiot you have
to do something that didn't already
exist which is scary I mean my brain
told me a million times who do you think
you are coming up with this and then one
day you wake up and you go well what if
it is me also if you want to learn from
other women successful entrepreneurs
check out my 2:54 girlboss series it's
free the link to join is in the
description below when I was selling
copiers door-to-door I had a very clear
vision of what my life was gonna be like
from day one I just I never tried to
hide that I was the girl in my apartment
with the red backpack rule number five
start small think big thanks was
profitable from the first month that I
was in business and I I'm in of the
belief system for me in my journey to
start small think big and scale fast and
a lot of people want to start big and
think big and oftentimes get ahead of
themselves and and that can end wildly
successfully but it can also cause a lot
of problems and you dilute yourself down
a lot and you know then you have a lot
of other people you're answering to so
that just was the journey that I took
you know I mean is I started it with
five grand I've never had any outside
funding and whatever money I made from
selling Spanx I just put back into the
business I love that start small think
big rule number six get off the
autopilot one of the things I also do is
I like to go up to people at Spanx and I
say I'm always trying to get people off
autopilot like if you think about it
everything we do almost everything we do
in life is autopilot we're doing things
exactly the way someone else
showed us how to do it or taught us how
to do it well if you're doing things
exactly the way everyone else is there's
no there's not going to be any real
significant change there's not going to
be a really meaningful potential
breakthrough so I always go up to people
at Sphinx and say if nobody showed you
how to do your job how would you be
doing it and I'll say just sit with that
you know I'm always like I'll stop
myself often and just say okay you know
this is how I've been doing it but is
this right and give yourself the time to
think about it so I ask people to do
that
rule number seven start with why the
best advice I would give a female
founder looking to launch a female
centric company or product is to start
with the why and continue to lead with
why and be very authentic in your
message stay vulnerable be yourself
through the process at Spanx when I
first started it I observed how
companies were treating me as a consumer
and I was very determined to be one of
my customers and to be authentically
connected to them
rule number eight hire your weaknesses
in the early days I mean as an
entrepreneur you're every department so
I was the before and after but model
literally I took a picture of my own but
took it to Kinkos got it laminated with
and without Spanx on stood in the stores
and I'm like hey look what this can do
for you I was I was like the packer and
shipper I was the head of sales I was
everything and you learned very quickly
what you're good at and what you're not
good at and what you enjoy and what you
don't enjoy and there's usually a
correlation between the two and so I
often say as soon as you can afford to
hire your weaknesses and a few years
into Spanx it was abundantly clear that
the lane that I needed to stay in was
inventing selling promoting Spanx
actually he's never advertised Spanx
it's 18 years old and the first time
we've ever even sampled an ad was to in
16 and so I was sort of the the
advertisement and and me being out in
the field talking about the product and
sharing the story of the why why we're
making this why it's better was a big
part of the formula and I needed someone
to be in
the company day-to-day running the daily
operations rule number nine solve a
problem you were a frustrated consumer I
was and you decided to try to solve a
problem what was the problem you were
trying to solve well I couldn't figure
out what to wear under white pants and I
was a frustrated consumer the
undergarment options at that time were
not great right we had underwear that
left a panty line shape girdles that
were really thick and uncomfortable and
then they invented the thong which just
put underwear exactly where we have been
trying to get it out of or so so I was
like yeah I don't know and listen at the
time that I invented Spanx and for the
guys in the audience or some of the
ladies who don't know what Spanx is it's
just I invented an undergarment that
filled the gap between traditional
underwear and those heavy-duty shapers
and I was interested in giving women a
smooth canvas like I love clothes I love
you know to be able to wear them but
just like a painter if you don't have
the right canvas it affects the whole
painting and the options weren't great
and they could be seen they left lines
they left bulges so that's what caused
me to to invent the first product which
was the first ever Spanx the footless
pantyhose and rule number 10 the last
wandering for a very special bonus clip
is focus on impact I would say for the
next hundred years I think entrepreneurs
and business people should be
considering two things one is the social
impact I'm really thrilled to see that
businesses are really having a social
conscious and what they're producing and
how they're producing it
but also a much more feminine approach
to business I think that business
traditionally has been very masculine in
the way that it's been done and I went
about Spanx and such a feminine way with
much more feminine principles and I
think when that's more balanced on the
planet we're all going to be better off
now I've got a special bonus script from
Sarah on how to find your true path that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions let's go from just
watching a video to taking action here
we go question number one where do you
just need to start small from your big
idea number two what would the most
courageous version of you do right now
and number three what's the weakness
that you need to hire for I had wanted
to be a lawyer my father was a trial
attorney and I used to actually ask to
get out of school growing up to watch
him and closing arguments and I debated
all through high school I debated in
college and I'm basically a really bad
test taker and so I bombed the LSAT and
I bombed it not once but twice and so it
set my life on on a different course for
you know I would say things like that
happen and then you end up you know like
those those moments in your life where
you think I can't believe this is
happening to me is oftentimes life's way
of nudging you and just letting you know
you're off course
if you want more Sara Blakely check out
the first top ten I made on her the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there one of the biggest things
I can say is differentiate yourself I
had always wanted to be a lawyer and I
basically failed the LSAT